plus de 170 rassemblements sont prévus
aujourd'hui à travers le pays des
manifestations à l'appel de syndicats et
d'organisations de la jeunesse pour
réclamer des hausses de salaires et de
meilleures conditions de travail à
quelques semaines de la présidentielle
la crise sanitaire et le retour de
l'inflation relancer le débat sur
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat des
français pour en parler nous sommes en
direct avec cédric l'enfant porte parole
du syndicat alternatif des instituteurs
et professeurs des écoles de l'île de la
réunion
cédric l'enfant bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous une nouvelle journée de
mobilisation partout en france avec
plusieurs revendications en métropole
quelles sont vos revendications sur
l'île de la réunion est ce que vous
rejoignez le même combat
bien sûr bien sûr qu'on revoie le même
combat que la métropole même si ici on
est correctement payé puisqu'on a une
sur indexation on sait que un enseignant
qui commence à 1550 euros en métropole
c'est indécent par rapport à un bac +5
et par rapport au travail qu'on fait on
n'oublie pas non plus tous les précaires
les avais sachets des assistants
d'éducation qui ont des contrats
précaires et sous payés et donc c'est
indécent par rapport au travail qu'ils
font et à la à l'importance du métier
d'assistant d'éducation qui s'occupe de
la vie scolaire de tous les élèves de ce
france et navarre et les avais sage qui
sont des accompagnants en d'élèves en
situation de handicap qui oeuvre tant
bien que mal avec des petits salaires et
sans moyens pour essayer d'inclure des
élèves en situation de handicap dans les
écoles voilà qui on pense aussi à tous
les atouts des tous les précaires dans
le dans le secteur privé aussi à une
destruction des services publics mais on
est là on soutient aussi de tous les
salariés du privé qui se serait fait
relève parce qu'ils ont des petits
salaires
et parce que parce que si si ils font
grève ils sont ils seront pas reconduits
dans leur contrat donc voilà c'est la
solidarité qui prime aujourd'hui et la
convergence des luttes
justement cette convergence des luttes
c'est est essentiel on sait que c'est
une grève au nom de l'ensemble de la
fonction publique on l'a dit aussi des
salariés du privé seront à présent
aujourd'hui dans un contexte assez tendu
puisque le pouvoir d'achat c'est la
principale préoccupation des français
alors que nous sommes à quelques mois
des élections présidentielles
et oui le pouvoir d'achat on doit
pouvoir vivre et travailler dignement
c'est bien de travailler mais c'est bien
de travailler avec un salaire décent et
c'est vrai qu'à une smicardisation de
l'ensemble des salariés du privé comme
du public malheureusement aujourd'hui on
est en train de négocier des miettes si
on travaille il faut avoir un travail
pour vivre dignement tout simplement et
donc la convergence des luttes aller là
c'est que ce soit privé ou public la
france est un pays un pays riche les
sociétés du cac 40 ont fait des
dividendes de toute l'année et donc
c'est important que ces richesses dont
le fruit est long le travail c'est
certainement vient des manutentionnaires
des travailleurs et des travailleuses
doit être redistribué équitablement
voilà donc qu'on dit ici il ne faut pas
être jaloux de ceux qui ont plus il faut
être révolté de ce qu'ils ont trop et
solidaire de ceux qui ont moi en tout
cas on entend du bruit derrière vous
puisque vous êtes dans cette
manifestation sur l'île de la réunion
vous vous êtes représentant vous êtes
porte-parole du système dit alternatif
des instituteurs et des professeurs des
écoles les écoles où c'était un petit
peu le cafouillage récemment avec tous
ces protocoles sanitaires qui ont été
mises en place quelle est aujourd'hui la
situation des enseignants justement
balade situation des enseignants aller
catastrophique puisque il ya beaucoup de
collègues qui se retrouvent en arrêt
maladie à cause de la coved justement et
non remplacés donc c'est la double peine
à la fois on peut pas aller travailler
parce que il ya des enseignants qui ont
qui sont positifs et la double peine
parce que il ya les enfants n'ont pas
assez de remplaçants n'ont pas de
d'instituteurs devant le devant le
devant est tout simplement et donc c'est
la double peine et puis on gère avec les
moyens du bord voilà comme vous comme
vous le savez monsieur monsieur blanc
car notre ministre de l'éducation
nationale a annoncé le nouveau protocole
la veille de la rentrée depuis ibiza
petit clin d'oeil d'ailleurs eu du
suspense et on avait les petits colliers
de fleurs etc c'est du mépris en fait
pour l'éducation nationale pour le
personnel et pour l'ensemble des élèves
et des parents d'avoir un tel a dû tel
mépris c'est l'amateurisme dans la mise
en place de ce protocole je rappelle
qu'à la réunion on a le taux d'incidence
de plus élevée et pourtant on a allégé
encore le protocole là les mairies n'ont
pas les moyens humains et matériels de
désinfecter correctement et on a un
recteur une rectrice et 1 et un préfet
qui nous dit non tout va bien il n'y a
pas de contamination dans les écoles
c'est faux c'est faux donc on se tendent
pandémie il est temps de penser au
personnel et aux élèves et si on veut
vraiment combattre cette pandémie est là
il faut y mettre les moyens et quand on
n'a pas les moyens vaut mieux fermer les
écoles la continuité pédagogique et on
est pour favre défavorable et sans
moyens on ne peut pas y arriver à cette
qualité pédagogique donc c'est bien de
faire venir de laisser les enfants dans
les écoles mais pas à n'importe quel
prix et pas au prix de la santé des
collègues je le rappelle merci beaucoup
en tout cas cédric l'enfant d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole
du syndicat alternatif des instituteurs
et professeurs des écoles sur l'île de
la réunion